[Musica]
l'uomo è l'unica specie in grado di
costruire armi per uccidere se stesso
sono rimasto abbastanza attonita la
prima volta che ho sentito questa frase
ma poi ho studiato biologia e ho
iniziato a lavorare sull'inquinamento
marino e ho iniziato a capire che non è
poi così falsa
l'impatto dell'uomo sugli oceani sta
diventando sempre più profondo ma è come
se l'inquinamento marino non fosse
ancora percepito come una vera e propria
minaccia alla nostra salute
è come se noi sapessimo della presenza
dell'inquinamento in mare ma non
volessimo vedere quella linea sottile
che collega le nostre vite alla salute
degli oceani
io ho sempre avuto una particolare
passione per l'acqua noto da quando ero
veramente molto piccola ed adolescente
ho iniziato a fare immersioni resta da
proprio durante una delle prime missioni
che sono rimasta letteralmente
ipnotizzata dalla bellezza di quel mondo
sottomarino quel mondo che abbiamo
silenziosamente violentato i cui segni
però sono molto ben visibili là sotto
sono una biologa marina e studio
l'impatto dell'uomo sul mare e
lo faccio non solo perché voglio
conoscere esplorare ma lo faccio anche
perché voglio comunicarlo agli altri a
chi non si occupa di scienza lo faccio
perché voglio lasciare alle generazioni
future 1 c'erano più pulito in modo che
anch'esse possano innamorarsi come è
successo al medico e le bellezze
sottomarine possano continuare questa
catena di protezione degli oceani che
non si fermerà più
oggi voglio portarvi in un viaggio un
viaggio al confine tra il visibile e
l'invisibile
un viaggio al confine tra il
macroscopico e il microscopico un
viaggio attraverso l'oceano per scoprire
come l'inquinamento da plastica ai
contaminanti chimici possono influenzare
la nostra salute
e danneggiare il nostro pianeta
spesso l'inquinamento marino è percepito
come un qualcosa che ci interessa
solamente le comunità costiere o di cui
solo esse sono responsabili in realtà
dovete sapere che più dell'ottanta per
cento dei rifiuti presenti in mare
in realtà di origine terrestre e viene
dare anche molto lontane dalla costa e
poi arrivano in mare attraverso apporti
fluviali attraverso l'immissione diretta
anche attraverso diciamo eventi
meteorologici avversi e una volta giunti
in mare soltanto una piccola percentuale
realtà galleggia meno del 15 per cento è
visibile sul pelo dell'acqua
la stragrande maggioranza invece affonda
e va a formare ed implementare delle
vere e proprie discariche
sottomarine
pensate che siamo riusciti a far
arrivare la plastica persino nel posto
più buio keane esplorato e più profondo
dei nostri oceani a 11.000 metri di
profondità presso la fossa delle
marianne
ma lo sapevate che esistono degli
ammassi di rifiuti grandi quanto cinque
volte la superficie dell'italia che
stanno attualmente galleggiando sugli
oceani
infatti negli oceani esistono delle
gigantesche
correnti che si chiamano vortex proprio
perché hanno un andamento circolare
vorticoso e continuo e queste
trasportano i rifiuti e le accumulano al
loro interno e quindi giorno dopo giorno
anno dopo anno si sono venuti a formare
questi grandi ammassi che impropriamente
vengono chiamati isole di plastica ma in
realtà non sono per niente delle isole
sono dei veri e propri accumuli di
rifiuti galleggianti
la stragrande maggioranza di questi
rifiuti è costituita da plastica monouso
e attrezzi da pesca
infatti il fenomeno delle reti fantasma
ad esempio è sempre più diffuso nei mari
di tutto il mondo le reti fantasma sono
delle reti da pesca che vengono
volontariamente o spesso
involontariamente abbandonate nel mare e
queste la sotto continuano a pescare ma
poi non c'è nessun pescatore che le
salpa bordo e quindi gli animali
intrappolati muoiono di una lenta agonia
ma la plastica può essere anche ingerita
infatti la maggior parte dei cetacei che
vengono trovati spiaggiati lungo le
coste del nostro pianeta vengono trovati
con chili e chili di plastica
all'interno del loro stomaco per non
parlare poi della situazione degli
uccelli marini
pensate che gli adulti
cibano con la plastica i propri pulcini
quindi piccoli crescono già con la
plastica all'interno ed hanno gravissimi
problemi di malnutrizione
problemi di crescita in molti di essi
non riescono a raggiungere il grado
colta
ma se la plastica
non in trappola con non venisse ingerita
qual è il suo destino
beh se questa bolli bottiglietta finisse
in mare sarebbe soggetta
immediatamente all'azione dei raggi
ultravioletti del sole o alla forza
meccanica delle onde ea molti altri
agenti e quindi mese dopo mesi anni dopo
anni il materiale plastico inizia a
frammentarsi a degradarsi sempre più e
quindi una singola bottiglietta di
plastica che adesso la vediamo può
trovarsi in mare nella sua forma
invisibile le microplastiche
le micro classiche sono particelle di
plastica di dimensioni inferiori ai 5 mm
magari vi state chiedendo ma come ci
arrivano in mare le microplastiche beh
ci sono le micro classiche primarie che
diventano così piccole ancor prima di
raggiungere il mare ad esempio quelle
micro sfere abrasive che vengono incluse
molti cosmetici vengono rilasciate
attraverso gli scarichi urbani e
raggiungere l'ambiente ci sono quelle
microfibre che sono dei minuscoli
filamenti
rilasciati dalle nostre lavatrici ogni
volta che l'abbiamo capi di
abbigliamento in tessuto sintetico
ci sono poi le microplastiche secondarie
chiamate così perché diventano così
piccole in un secondo momento cioè dopo
il processo di degradazione
frammentazione gli oggetti di plastica
più grande proprio come è successo alla
nostra bottiglia di plastica
uno dei grandi problemi legati alle
microplastiche è che possono essere
facilmente ingerite infatti come grandi
animali ingeriscono plastica i piccoli
animali marini possono ingerire plastica
nella loro nella sua forma microscopica
diverse anni fa mi sono chiesta ma come
mai gli animali marini dovrebbero
ingerire microplastiche
belli microplastiche
nell'ambiente acquatico attirano sulla
propria superficie
tantissimi composti presenti nell'acqua
questi composti vanno a formare un vero
e proprio tappetino molecolare tutto
intorno alla superficie che si chiama
eco corona ora questa eco corona funge
da terreno di colonizzazione per molti
microrganismi marini come batteri marini
micro alghe funghi marini e quindi si
viene proprio a formare un vero e
proprio micro habitat intorno ad una
minuscola particella di plastica
e questa si chiama plus triste era
dunque la prassi sfera vivendo produce
tantissime molecole che rilascia
nell'ambiente circostante tantissimi
odori e quindi le microplastiche odorano
come il cibo per molti organismi marini
ecco perché questi sono tentati dal
catturarle e quindi ingerirle su questa
epoca rona quindi su questo tappetino di
molecole si trovano anche tante sostanze
che sono tossiche per la vita
questi contaminanti chimici possono
intervenire
provocare degli effetti dannosi in
diverse maniere ma un effetto che mi ha
particolarmente interessato qualche anno
fa e che poi ho studiato diciamo durante
il mio lavoro el interferenza endocrina
dunque gli interferenti endocrini sono
delle sostanze o dei miscugli di
sostanze che hanno la capacità di
disturbare il sistema ormonale
infatti la maggior parte di essi opera
semplicemente mi mandò gli ormoni
infatti la loro struttura chimica e
molto molto simile a quella degli ormoni
non solo umani ma anche animali e quindi
una volta che entrano in un organismo
agiscono al loro posto e il corpo non
riesce a riconoscerli come dei composti
estranei per cui a me piace chiamarli
impostori molecolari proprio perché
agiscono come dei veri e propri
impostori
gli interferenti endocrini possono agire
in diverse
misure ad esempio possono provocare
infertilità possono provocare problemi
di sviluppo e di crescita problemi
riproduttivi
obesità diabete e molti altri disturbi e
malattie ma nell'ambiente marino mia
curiosità molto uno degli effetti che è
la confusione sessuale
infatti adesso voglio raccontarvi un
aneddoto un po scientifico allora
qualche decade fa dei biologi marini
hanno iniziato a osservare in diverse
parti del pianeta delle
decimazioni di lumachine di mare sono
riusciti poi a correlare queste
decimazioni di questi molluschi ad alte
concentrazioni di tbt nell'ambiente
dunque il tbt anche definito tributi
stagno è praticamente un composto che
veniva fino agli anni ottanta aggiunto
alle vernici antivegetative che sono
usate per rivestire la chiglia delle
navi ed evitare che organismi marini
leva dono a colonizzare
beh questo di bt è un biocida e un
potentissimo interferente endocrino e
pensate che tra i suoi vari effetti è
riuscito a mascolinizzato le femmine di
queste le macchine il tbt ha
letteralmente fatto crescere un pene
sulle femmine di questi gasteropodi
siamo davvero arrivati a un limite
dobbiamo sapere che tutti questi
contaminanti sono di origine antropica e
proprio a causa dell'uomo se finiscono
in mare e questo ci serve a far capire
che l'uomo e la e l'oceano sono
strettamente correlati tra loro mi piace
tantissimo una frase di rachel carson
rachel carson è stata una
la biologa una scrittrice una forte
attivista statunitense che grazie alle
sue denunce è riuscita a far abolire
l'uso del ddt che è anche che ha chiesto
un potente interferente endocrino e
belle e scriveva in natura niente esiste
da solo ma l'uomo è parte integrante
della natura e la sua guerra contro la
natura è inevitabilmente una guerra
contro se stesso
beh tutto questo sembra una triste
storia ma in realtà voglio dirvi una
cosa
qualche anno fa ho incontrato di persona
la fantastica oceanografa si girl e lei
durante il nostro discorso mi ha detto
martin all'inquinamento da plastica a un
lato negativo ma anche un lato positivo
io trovi mi sono chiesta ma quale
potrebbe essere il lato positivo
il lato negativo è che la plastica sta
distruggendo i nostri oceani ma il lato
positivo è che non lo sappiamo e quindi
possiamo ancora fare qualcosa per
salvare il nostro pianeta
attualmente
io magari tutti voi ci stiamo chiedendo
ma che cosa possiamo fare in realtà io
onestamente non penso che ci sia la
soluzione per eccellenza io penso che
sia necessario uno sforzo integrato tra
istituzioni amministrazioni locali
comunità
scienziati innovatori comunicatori sono
già stati fatti molti passi nella nella
direzione giusta come ad esempio
l'abolizione dell'uso delle
microplastiche all'interno dei cosmetici
o il recentissimo disegno di legge del
trentino nel rilasciare palloncini
nell'atmosfera
ma c'è bisogno di un passo in più e c'è
bisogno della collaborazione di tutti
perché tutti siamo cittadini del pianeta
e ogni decisione che prendiamo ogni
passo che facciamo deve lasciare
un'impronta blu
io dico sempre l'inquinamento inizia
dalle nostre scelte per cui
che facciamo la scelta giusta scegliamo
il pianeta grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]